[Music]
in destroyed collection news submitted
by abstinence a man is suing his parents
for eighty six thousand dollars after
they tossed his porn collection
Oh eighty six thousand I should be suing
for more that's feel like blow what how
big was this collection why is it 86,000
though like that specific number yeah is
it a collectible porn feel like your
mental health is worth more than eighty
six thousand dollars an artistic porn
online I don't really understand there's
so much fun Google it Google search
support the artists I just don't want to
be like how does porn work and then that
is gonna follow me around the internet
forever but I I believe in supporting
performers so I paid for all of my
really that's nice I just need like a
little trailer to get my mind going and
then I'm good oh yeah you also gotta
follow the story so I'm subscribed every
season and series all this series what
theory there's one called the Louisiana
losers you're lying because we all know
you like Realty [ __ ] alright there's one
called the Louisiana Realty bus they go
from house to house to house and you
gotta got to know what's happening at
the next house try over here
what what what happened so this man he
got divorced and he moved back into his
so that's what he really needed that
porn collection
yeah he stayed there for ten months and
he would do chores instead of paying
rents oh my god
sounds like a big baby yeah I hate this
guy already yeah so I wonder he's the
forest yeah mm-hmm you probably yeah
it's Polly's parents fault so his
parents so he ended up moving out
because there was like police had to be
called to the house for a domestic
situation I don't know the details of
that but he ended up leaving their home
so then the parents took she beat him up
huh
the way well he's already divorced at
this point oh so the parents beat him up
okay he was a lady with the frying pan
that's what happened yes
the parents took some of his boxes like
his belongings to his new home and he
said that there was a lot of his
belongings missing which was an
ungrateful moving boxes full of movies
and two boxes and sex toys is what was
missing boxes of sex toys so his parents
saw this and said [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
threw it away yeah he's a freak so his
parents
does he have 12 boxes I mean if they're
not DVDs and they're VHS and he's been
collecting these from like the 90s
that's a lot yeah just like beanie
babies they're not gonna be worth
anything
yes he's saying that he sent one officer
44 emails worth of movies that he says
that were destroyed all the titles yeah
I memorized 44 emails not just out of
print but the entire studio making it
dissolve and that was 20 years of years
ago oh my gosh I can't see yeah
collectibles right they might be
vehicles but the Baron said he's like
believe it or not one reason for why I
destroyed your porn was for your own
mental and emotional health I would have
done the same if I have found a kilo
crack cocaine someday I hope you will
understand so the dad said that back
when he was in high school and in
college when the kid was in high school
in college he got kicked out of school
because he was selling porn to other
students worth that much money cuz he
would sell it and he would people would
pay for it cuz back then they didn't get
it for free this is what this is why I
tell people you should follow your
passion because this guy obviously was
keeping his passion in his closet and he
wanted to work in the porn industry but
he was keeping in his parents closet
parents club you didn't take it with him
he didn't go out after the whole high
school and college thing the parents
were like and I told you if I ever found
porn in my home I will destroy it so I
learned where did you find the number
86,000 so it the collection he estimates
it to be worth $29,000 and that's like
rounding up cuz it's actually it gets
down to the center there's a 28,000
nine hundred and forty dollars and
seventy two cents and so he added on
like with emotional distress and fifty
thousand dollars of emotionally should
start deducting for the [ __ ] food he
ate [ __ ] yeah wear and tear of this
[ __ ] broom this direction like I
still being a storage unit right the
stress that they brought up upon is what
I like about this guy though is he's so
bold about his porn love for porn that
most people would be embarrassed to even
address it like if my parents threw it
away I'll be like yeah I probably
shouldn't have left it there you know
I'm like oh [ __ ] they found it you know
yeah this guy is more like where's my
[ __ ] porn I didn't add my pores my
poor Betty like who the [ __ ] does that
that's crazy
he ended up emailing to his dad saying
if you had a problem with my belongings
you should have stated that at the time
and I would have gone elsewhere instead
you chose to keep quiet and behave
vindictively Oh what is this guy 40 oh
my god watch what a [ __ ] how did he
get a wife at one point maybe he was
good-looking
hmm I don't have a photo masturbator
idly what what you just said what
happened what happened to what do you
mean you see you think you're pretty
cute you hear what she said
yeah you hear a masturbator ugly and
what people who master Jo and I were
like hey oh welcome back
where were you I thought she said he's a
masturbator
and then and I thought she said wait I'm
cute and I was like how do you draw the
line on mice away what are you saying
wait so you don't masturbate no I do
that I was making a joke okay since I
got married but everyone here yesterday
started dating yeah but we masturbate
like it's a sport yeah it's separate
yeah four years ago it is separate
masturbating is if it's training force
it's it's it's training for sex it's the
practice for the game it's like you
still play basketball but you still need
to go to the gym also it's a different
world like
differents masturbating is like gang
banging and my husband's like my husband
he's the star this guy's a piece of [ __ ]
though for real what did he have
flashlights sex toys what are guys next
is life
well he has that big ass that's why you
need it to boxes you know guy things are
just you know it's a lot of space yeah
you know you need to like half a torso
or something yeah it's like you need
more you know to put it together than
pieces yeah like girls they could get
away with a little vibrator it does its
greed you know the one thing when I
wasn't in a relationship was the weight
of the guy I wish I had like a torso
like a sandbag or something cuz I missed
the weight I think four guys - nothing
beats vagina yeah like there's just
nothing no sex toys as good it doesn't
work but for girls like I think yeah the
vibrators vibrators definitely replaces
you think no it doesn't really good
shower yeah still rather have dick yeah
same I remember I want a dick in a
shower yeah I think you need a
masturbate girlfriend no the reason I've
asked for you anymore is so that it's
better when I have sex with my husband
mmm have you tried edgy Oh
have you tried edgy you have the
discipline for that no but I try to I
try to it's like right when you're about
to like orgasm or not over you stop and
then you put on your pets and you walk
away like a good question you do it
again no no but you do it again so
you get to a point where you're about to
come and then you stop and then like
maybe thirty minutes later you do it
again and then you stop and then like
what do they know to do evident so then
by the time you have sex like the best
[ __ ] orgasm ever but I've never been
able to do it I'm doing it I can't tell
you so much
da I tried it because I was like I'm
gonna [ __ ] go in and do this shit's
like a train and then as soon as I'm
about to edge I'm like [ __ ] I'm just
gonna finish I got angry I tried it once
and I was like I'm mad like NADCA yeah
I'm doing this it's like someone turned
you on and said no and then they walked
away you're like why and in you're mad
at yourself
yeah why did I make this rule up like
when you're on a diet and you're looking
at the food like why is a cupcake back
do this to myself
exactly wait so what if you end up
having the best sex ever in your entire
life you wouldn't do it again wow it's
just hard getting to that point yeah
yeah have to do a person but getting
this yeah get really angry
it's like someone walking up from a nap
you know like that kind of anger
disturbed or yeah like I was like having
such a good time and then I just had to
come back to reality without any sort of
any sort of closure on that that's not
so you're having a good dream and then
it's like nope gotta go to work that's
the word sometimes I'm like bring me
back into the world bring me back into
the world have you ever gone back into a
dream that you guys dream again I try to
do that so bad recently because I ended
up seeing 90s Brad Pitt you dream oh my
god which movie will be one of these I
don't remember like I remember all these
movies been like I just remember like
what do you like though and he was
shirtless on my bed but because of my
dream I'm like I'm still [ __ ] loyal
cuz I'm like oh
I'm married but then I woke up and I
realized oh my god it's a dream oh my
god I get back in that dream I've had so
many dreams of ever them wanting me he
wanted me so bad and I was like I'm
sorry I'm gonna good English mmm
Marshall I'm in a relationship I
actually have dreams that I'm cheating
on my husband and I wake up and I'm like
Shawn I have to tell you something that
shirts getting real burned right now
he's like [ __ ] it's gonna have a brown
bear the shape of iron every time I wake
up in a minute I'm like I had a bad
dream he's like who'd you cheat on me
with
I feel like I'm just perpetually afraid
that I am going to cheat on my a
manifesting in in your dream yeah like I
know he's gonna wake up one day me like
why what if he was just like yeah go
ahead Greg I don't care but I care no
they're so cute they have matching like
outfits for every holiday unless they
like a bunch of matching outfits in the
underwear
yeah like that he's more naked than me
and he gets down to like a speedo and
shows people uncomfortable he also has
like he's been like working out for
football since he was like four so he
has quads that could literally strangle
you then they're so thick but when he's
wearing a like a speedo it just looks
really funny yeah I mean I should go the
bathroom Oh